on va cours les carrés des petits soucis
on a trouvé à Emmaüs c'est l'une des
créations que Léo et Daniel viennent de
démarrer ils vont réaliser un drapeau
des fiertés avec des messages que vont
laisser les visiteurs tout au long de
leur résidence
[Musique]
que c'est de la poste c'est le portable
de tous les visiteurs pour laisser un
message avec l'université pourquoi c'est
important la respecte les la tolérance
en pratique on doit pratiquer la
tolérance
le projet a démarré en 1982 au moment
des premières élections libres en
Argentine tchatcheo et Giannone se lance
dans une approche artistique autour de
la démocratie leur choix rendre hommage
aux communautés LGBT du monde entier
à un autre exposition la prochaine
position
à l'Argentine notre lieu que on va faire
l'exposition
c'est plus qu'une exposition c'est un
manifeste qui va passer par Los Angeles
Paris ou encore Copenhague inspiré par
d'autres artistes Cocteau Julie Marot ou
encore Tom de Pékin
inséparable dans la vie dans le travail
et dans l'oeuvre aussi le couple se met
en scène avec toujours beaucoup d'humour
nous sommes Tchatcho et Giannone un
artiste que nous avons créé en 2003 pour
travailler ensemble savoir c'est la
peinture et tout notre travail repose
sur la couleur mais nous utilisons aussi
d'autres techniques comme la broderie
l'exposition et la résidence sont
ouvertes au public jusqu'au 24 avril au
transpalette à Bourges
[Musique]